i know this will be hard
for uh for many people but by reducing
your contacts in the workplace you will
help slow transmission
second from this friday we will further
extend the legal requirement to wear a
face mask to most to most public indoor
venues including theaters and cinemas
there will be of course exceptions where
it's not practical such as when eating
drinking exercising or singing
third we'll also make the nhs covered
pass mandatory for entry into nightclubs
and venues where large crowds gather
including
unseated indoor venues with more than
500 people
unseated outdoor venues with more than
four thousand people
and any venue with more than ten
thousand people
the nhs
covered pass can still be obtained with
two doses but we will keep this under
review as the boosters roll out
and having taken clinical advice since
the emergence of omicron a negative
lateral flow test will also be
sufficient
as we set out in plan b
we will give businesses a week's notice
so this will come into force in a week's
time
helping to keep these events and venues
open at full capacity while giving
everyone who attends them confidence
that those around them have done the
responsible thing to minimize risk to
others
as omicron spreads in the community we
will also introduce daily tests for
contacts instead of isolation so we keep
people safe while minimizing the
disruption to daily life
and of course we will take every step to
ensure our nhs is ready for the
challenges ahead
but the single biggest thing that every
one of us can do is to get our jabs and
crucially to get that booster as soon as
our turn
arrives
one year to the day since the uk became
the first country in the world to
administer a coveted vaccine into the
arms of margaret keenan we've opened up
the vaccine booster to all those over 40
and we're reducing the gap between
second dose and booster to a minimum of
just three months
our heroic nhs staff and volunteers have
already done almost 21 million boosters
including reaching 84 percent of all the
eligible over 80s
but we need to go further and faster
still
because our scientists are absolutely
confident that your immune your immune
response will be stronger if you've been
boosted and while you're at it please
get your flu jab too
let's do everything we can to protect
ourselves and our loved ones this winter
and to reduce the pressures on our nhs
as we learn more so we will be guided
by the hard medical data around four key
criteria
the efficacy of our vaccines and our
boosters the severity of omicron
the speed of its spread and the rate of
hospitalizations
we will constantly monitor
the data
and keep it under review and of course
we must be humble in the face of this
virus
but if and indeed as soon as it becomes
clear that the boosters are capable
of holding
this omicron
variant
and we've boosted enough people to do
that job of keeping omicron in
equilibrium then we will be able to move
forward as before so please everybody
play your part and get boosted i'm now
going to hand over to chris to do the
slides thank you prime minister first
slide please
i wanted to situate this uh
uh i wanted to situate this uh initially
on where we are with delta because
what's happening is omnicron is coming
on the back of a still high rate of
delta transmission and hospitalization
so in the first slide what we have is
the number of people testing positive
for covid in the uk
and that has been drifting upwards not
at a very rapid rate but it has been
drifting upwards uh the omicron data
aren't really going to be visible in
this
for a few days but they will become
visible over time
next slide please
the number of people in the hospital
with kovid in the uk
has because of the booster vaccination
program in particular i've been drifting
down
until this point in time with the
numbers going into hospital uh reducing
although that's now stabilized slightly
and now the boosters are particularly
going to protect and are protecting
people who are in the highest risk
categories as the prime minister has
said
next slide please
and the number of people in the uk who
are dying uh has again gradually been
decreasing over time but uh is still uh
a daily average
of 121 deaths from kovid
so we still have a significant issue
with covid and i think anybody who
speaks to anyone working in the nhs
would say that is on top of an
incredibly busy system
next slide please
in terms of our main major counter
measures of course the biggest one as
the prime minister has said is boosting
and this is steadily increasing so we
now have over a third of those who are
eligible have already had a booster and
they are by and large the most
vulnerable third but there's still
people who are in uh in higher risk
groups have not been boosted
and of course we have to move down those
groups and that is going to become
absolutely critical we think
as we move on to into a period where
omicron becomes significant and probably
then becomes dominant
next slide please
and if this is a just a data data just
to uh show
quite how effective with the variance
we've had to date vaccination
can be and what it compares is in the
dark lines the hospitalization rate
in the the blue black bars
in those who are
unvaccinated
and in the orange bars those who are
vaccinated with two doses this is
largely protecting against delta
but as you can see at every age
a really substantial improvement
in your protection
next slide please
so now we move on to the data on omicron
and these are data probably people have
seen their versions of in uh in media
over the last few days but i think they
do need uh point needs sort of uh
fleshing out a bit
so these are the number of people
testing positive for covert 19 in south
africa at this point in time the big
increase in kovid in south africa is
virtually all
the omicron variant
and this is now spread all around south
africa and as you can see this is an
incredibly steep
increase
in rates
and we're now seeing this translating
into increasing increases in
hospitalization so for example i was
talking to some of my colleagues from
south africa this afternoon and they
were saying that uh informal data still
to be uh still to be uh added to but
there was around about a 300
percent increase on hospitalizations uh
over the last week
uh so um some of those will have come in
with
omicron and some of them will come in as
a result of omnicron but the fact is
those numbers are going up very sharply
next slide please
so what's happening here in the uk well
i'm afraid that the data here are now uh
clear
what you can see here
is the uh number on the left
and on the right the percentage
of cases with a with what's called s
gene target failure this is a marker for
omicron virtually all the cases now
who've got this marker will have omicron
a very small number at the bottom will
not and as you can see whether you look
at the absolute count or the percentage
this is going up incredibly fast now
and as the prime minister has said this
is doubling at this point in time it may
slow down and the aim of the measures uh
announced by the prime minister is is to
slow things down but it's doubling
currently between two and three every
two and three days that is an
extraordinarily fast rate and you
therefore can get with very small
numbers to very large numbers really
quite quickly
the question obviously people recently
want to ask is will this feed through to
people in hospital and how quickly
and i think i'd just like to uh just
point out two realities
first of all i need the first one is a
good one but the moment the spread is in
younger people who would you would not
expect to go into hospital in this once
it starts moving up the ages and into
vulnerable groups that you'll start to
see that so there will be a lag as it
moves into more vulnerable groups
and then we know from previous ways and
this is not particularly surprising that
there is a delay between people becoming
infected with covid and ending up with
symptoms and then with hospitalization
so there's usually about a two week
delay we would therefore not expect
that these cases that the case rates in
hospital will start to go up for a
number of probably two to three weeks
and in that period if you're doubling up
at the speed we're talking about now we
move from very small numbers to really
substantial numbers and it will keep on
doubling
and that really is the reason
why these measures have been announced
by the prime minister as agreed by uh
ministers today
thank you very much thanks very much
chris uh patrick anything you want to
add
okay good uh well let's let's go to
members of the public uh then dave from
chester
our mandatory vaccinations being
considered likely on the eu and other
global nations and if not why
why is it acceptable to put measures on
our freedoms but not that on our
vaccination statuses
thanks dave well i said right at the
beginning of this pandemic that uh i
think or as soon as we were really
talking about vaccinations seriously
that i didn't want us to have a society
in a culture where we force people to
get vaccinated i don't think that's ever
been the the the way we do things in
this country and actually dave we've
been able to achieve uh through the
volunteerism of the british people
through their incredible public
spiritedness willingness to roll up
their their sleeves and get vaccinated
uh huge numbers huge proportions of our
of our population i think that uh there
is going to come a point if we can uh if
we can show that the
uh the vaccines are capable of of
holding the uh of omicron uh and that's
the the key thing that i think that we
need to to test well i do think that
we're to have to have a a conversation
about uh ways in which we uh we deal
with this uh pandemic because i want to
be absolutely clear with you i don't
believe we can keep going indefinitely
with
non-pharmaceutical
uh interventions uh i mean restrictions
on people's way of life uh where just
because uh a substantial proportion of
the population still sadly has not got
uh vaccinated and i think we're gonna
need to have a national conversation
about the the way forward and
uh and the other things that we can do
uh to protect those who are hard to
reach who haven't got vaccinated for one
reason another who may have medical
reasons why they can't get vaccinated
other ways of protecting them
but that is a stage that i think we will
come to if and when
we establish
as i hope that we will
that the
uh the booster is effective against
omicron and the booster is capable of of
holding omicron getting us back into
that uh equilibrium uh the the double
jabs uh got us into uh with uh with
delta if if you if you follow me so uh
it's at that moment i think we will have
to talk seriously about uh moving on uh
from uh the way we uh from thinking
about further uh further npis and and
thinking about other ways in which we we
protect people uh rachel from essex
rachel asked why can't fully vaccinated
british travelers stuck in red listed
countries
home uh when they turn instead of a
hotel quarantine hotels are too
expensive especially as this was
implemented at short notice not giving
travelers a chance to to get home well
uh rachel i think that's a very fair
challenge i think that uh given the way
omicron is now seeded around the world
and and not just in in red listed
countries i think we we will be uh
looking at the uh the red list and the
way that we uh we do it but uh it's it's
been very important in the immediate
pyradine response to omicron to have
very tough border measures uh to slow
the arrival of the
of the variant in this in this country
and that was the uh the objective of
those uh measures and continues to be
the objective of chris fat really honor
to add to
to that okay then let's go straight to
laura coons beggar bbc
news
thank you very much prime minister
you're tightening the rules again for
millions of people tonight
how can you stand at that lecture and
exactly where some of your team laughed
and joked about co-wood rules and tell
people they must now follow your new
instructions and are you really asking
the public to believe that you had no
idea what was going on under your own
roof
uh
actually the first thing i want to say
thanks very much laura the first thing i
want to say is that uh i know that uh
today uh allegra stratton has resigned
and i wanted to uh to pay tribute to her
because she has been uh in and in spite
of what uh
everybody has seen and uh uh and and
again i mean i make no excuses for uh
the frivolity with which the the subject
was handled uh in that in that rehearsal
uh that people saw in that clip uh and
there could be no excuse for it and it
was it was uh i can i can totally
understand how infuriating it was but i
want to say that allegra has been
a fine colleague has achieved a great
deal uh in her time in government and
was a particularly effective spokesman
for kopp 26 she coined uh the the coal
cars cash trees agenda and helped ready
to
to marshal and and to rally the the
world behind the agreement in cop uh 26
and uh i i really laura refused to give
me i wanted to to say that because i
think it's been a you know a sad day for
her as well uh as an infuriating uh
event for many many people around the
around the country and on that on that
point uh look i just want to i want to
repeat that the fundamental point is
that
i think
the
the the british public
um
notwithstanding the the point that you
make can see the vital importance of the
medical information that we're giving
and they can see the need uh to
take it uh to heart and and to act upon
it and that point has been proved time
and time again
and it's never been more conspicuous in
the way that the public has responded to
the uh the vaccine rollout and the way
that they've uh they've done the
responsible things so
i'm i'm i i take my encouragement uh
from the way uh the public have dealt
with it themselves um anushka astana of
of itv
prime minister you've only really agreed
to an investigation into what happened
on december the 18th last year because
of the video that emerged from this room
and allegra stratton's resignation seems
to further suggest that a party took
place despite the denials but we've also
had serious allegations about parties on
three other occasions so i want to ask
you why they aren't being investigated
is it because you haven't been caught
out in those cases or is it because
reports are true that you attended some
of them and to
the rest of you here can i ask how
worried you are about whether this
undermines public trust because the
polling suggests that it does do and
conservative mps are openly saying that
it's very hard now to mandate
the public to act
thanks very much well i repeat what i
said uh in the house and uh
earlier today uh the the cabinet
secretary uh will uh conduct an an
inquiry into the uh
into what took place on december the
18th uh as for other events that uh uh
other dates that you mentioned
as far as i'm aware the best of my
knowledge uh
and we have followed the rules
throughout and that is that is uh what
you would expect indeed we followed the
rule as far as i'm aware uh the rules
were followed on december the 18th as
well and uh you know i just i just
repeat that point but uh it's clearly
important that the cabinet secretary is
able to get to the bottom of it but in
the meantime on your you know your sort
of glo your global your big point again
uh anushka which is really the same as
as laura's i think the
overwhelmingly the the public see uh the
importance of the uh the messages that
they are getting via this
medium it is imperfect uh we do what we
can to explain uh what we think is is
necessary uh i know it's contentious i
know it's difficult and i know that
sometimes the messages are confusing uh
we do our absolute best to make it as as
clear as possible and we do everything
that we can uh to protect public health
that's what we're uh we're uh we're
driven by but uh chris and patrick you
were awesome i mean the measures work
with people follow them and that's been
shown time and time again during this so
it's incredibly important everyone
follows it it's everybody it's was
incredibly important throughout it's
going to be incredibly important going
forward
and it only works if we all do it
and
we're now facing um a viral variant
that's rapidly progressing
it's got a doubling time of between two
and three days
and measures need to be taken to try and
slow the spread of that variant as well
as and i think this is important
us all boosting our own defenses by
getting a booster jab so i think you
know the rules are there quite carefully
thought through and given scientific
evidence and they're there because
they're important and they're there for
everybody to stick to
yeah if i can just add to that i mean i
think
yeah we all know that people get very
angry
including colleagues and friends and
when they feel that it's unfair and that
prime minister said that in house
commons and he's said it said it today
that's quite different from people uh i
think wanting to actually know what's
going on
and then make decisions and i think
those two need to be separated and the
point about what we're trying to do is
trying to actually say look here are the
reasons this is moving very fast
doubling every two to three days
it is too early for us to be absolutely
confident about hospitalizations but i
think
you've seen how things have gone before
that's probably the way to bet and then
if we're pleasantly surprised no one
would be happier than than i would be
and patrick and the prime minister
and
we know that
it looked as if he was going to be able
to evade
vaccination and now clinically we know
that it can in terms of infection so we
know that is an issue therefore the
boost has become significantly more
important
and we know that we're going early now
so as to try and be able to slow this
down at an early stage of events and i
think it's laid out to people in a way
that is reasonable
irrespective of other things people want
to know the logic as to why they're
doing it and i hope we're trying to lay
out the logic of trying to do that
that's not in any way to try and move
away from the earlier point but i just
think those two should be kept separate
in people's minds
thanks very much uh chris beth rugby sky
um prime minister on allegra stratton's
resignation she resigned today she
looked broken as she did it how did you
feel
when you watched that statement
and watched what she said heard what she
said
and doesn't it lead to your leadership
being questioned
if others are taking responsibility for
things that happen in this place instead
of you taking responsibility and to the
scientists people are going to feel
pretty flat today listening to this
press conference they were told to get
their jobs to get their boosters that we
would have an irreversible path out of
lockdown that life would continue winter
comes
we are now being told that we have to
live with restrictions again is this
just the reality of living with covid so
this this is not just another year this
is happening but this is our lives now
for years to come i think people will be
worried about that thank you
yeah so just beth first on your first
point look yeah i repeat what i said to
to laura i think that allegra has been
an outstanding uh spokesperson but for
uh for the government for cop uh she did
she did an extraordinary job and i'm i'm
very very sorry to to lose her on your
point about responsibility i didn't just
take responsibility for things that
happened in this uh in this in this
building i take responsibility for
everything that happens in this in this
government and i've made i've made that
clear uh throughout the pandemic
on the um
question about
where we are now what that means for the
future
this virus has mutated a lot quickly
and
that is sort of what you'd expect at
this stage that you start to see more
mutations
this one's got a lot more than anyone
thought would arrive that quickly
and that's what's caused so many
concerns about it spreading very fast
the good news is that
so far it looks as though when you get
very high antibody levels with the
booster vaccine it's definitely having
some effect against it in the laboratory
studies we need to watch and see what
happens over the next few weeks as we
get more data on that so the boosters
remain incredibly important as a way of
increasing immunity
what we're on is a road from
pandemic to endemic where this becomes a
more sort of regular infection like flu
or something over time but we're in a
sort of bumpy transition for that and
that's going to be difficult and it is
difficult now and there are special
measures that need to happen now to try
and reduce the spread it doesn't mean
this is what happens in perpetuity
you would expect that over time this
becomes a virus which then has peaks
every year just in the way that flu does
perhaps
but it wouldn't be endlessly having new
variants that always escape
escape vaccines to some extent you would
also expect that the vaccine will need
to change over time just as the flu
vaccine changes year on year and you get
a slightly different one because the
thing continues to evolve a bit
so i think this is a
surprise change that's happened it's a
big one and yes it's going to make
everyone feel a bit sort of deflated
about it but there are things that can
be done i think the vaccines are going
to hold up to some extent here and i
think probably boosters will really push
that to a level uh that's going to be
important we need to test that and find
out and i don't think it's a harbinger
of what happens here after we may see we
will see more variants
and they will always cause some sort of
challenge but that challenge is the same
sort of challenge that you're going to
see year on year with other things as
well
over time
can i just add to that because i mean i
obviously completely agree
um we're in a transition period from a
point uh when we when the pandemic first
hit
uh in 2020 where we had to rely entirely
on social measures and had no medical
countermeasures
we will get to a stage where we have
multiple countermeasures probably lots
of different types of vaccines
antivirals we currently don't a whole
variety of others which is the way we
have dealt now
with very many infectious diseases we're
in that midpoint
we are immeasurably better off now than
we were with the vaccines we've got with
drugs with better hospital treatments a
whole bunch of things that are so much
better than they were
it would be much quicker getting over
this than it would have been if we the
same situation had hit us a year ago but
we shouldn't no point if we said that
there wouldn't be new variants
significant ones potentially and backed
in escape ones that said that's been
said by almost every i suspect every
media outlet that's uh represented here
repeatedly and for good reasons that's
the biological uh inevitability now when
it comes to this particular in the long
run i think the outlook is good but i
think we have to accept that it's not it
is still a difficult period and in terms
of this particular variant
the question i think is really going to
be
is this held by the current vaccines
with boosters
or are we actually going to have to do a
reformulation of that the vaccine at
least more vulnerable people
and that that is what we will need to do
over time and it may be actually what we
have is a transition period where the
booster holds it for a bit and that buys
us time and then we can actually get a
specific or what's called polyvalent
vaccine and that will allow us then to
in you know from later on in this year
be able to respond to it directly so i
think we should in a sense what i think
we should say is i can see why people
feel deflated but this is a kind of
setback this is not a this is not a
situation we're about to square one we
are we're kind of we're having to just
deal with it as we always thought we
might have to
said that you were furious about the
video you saw
about the mock press conference yes
how did you feel when you saw
electricity i'm sorry i'm sorry because
of the
of the
the huge uh
press of of uh meetings so far today i i
haven't been able to uh to see that i'm
course aware of what uh allegra has has
said and
i i i just repeat what i what i said i'm
i'm very grateful to her for everything
that she's uh that she's done and
uh i i i wish her uh all the very best
and and and we will certainly miss you
miss her uh here here in government but
i just want to add to uh to what what
chris has said on um this this crucial
period because i think that uh there is
a there is a at least of a strong
possibility uh that we will uh discover
in the course of the next few uh days
and weeks that
indeed the the combination of uh of two
jabs and under booster is capable of
holding omicron in uh in equilibrium in
the way that uh we want and and then as
i said we will be able uh to move
forward and it's always worth bearing in
mind that what we're doing today uh with
plan b is something that we we set out
uh back in september so this is not a a
deviation from uh what we the position
that we thought we might find ourselves
in as uh as winter uh winter set in uh
we always reckon that you would see a
spike in uh in disease and um
and an in infection uh actually delta
has been remarkably stable uh the
problem uh has has been the the sudden
emergence of omicron and the real spike
uh that it's producing and and given the
potential numbers that omicron could
produce
we just have to respond uh today in the
in the way that we are uh
from the mirror
thank you prime minister i thought i'd
have another goat anushka's question
because i don't think he quite answered
it
um can i ask why you've asked simon case
why you've tasked simon case with
investigating a party on december the
18th last year that you weren't at
rather than one on november the 27th
where you gave a speech that you were at
in breach of the rules by any reasonable
legal analysis and further to that will
you extend the inquiry some pieces
inquiry to include any other gatherings
events parties use the term that you
choose that took place in number 10 or
indeed in your flat
if there's evidence of them
so first of all uh um pippa on
the there this is a a huge as people
know this is a massive department of
state and there are people working flat
out uh the whole time uh working on all
sorts of uh of issues and they they work
they work extremely hard and uh
i according to
very very well respected uh civil
servants and uh advisers special
advisers that i've talked to about what
happened uh in the events that uh uh
that you describe uh no rules were
broken i've asked simon case to uh to
look at the other cabinet secretary
simon case to look at uh the uh the
december the 18th event i'm sure he'll
be uh considering uh all sorts of things
but as far as i'm concerned all the
evidence i can see is that uh
people in this building have stayed
within the rules if that turns out not
to be the case
and people wish to bring uh allegations
to uh to my attention or to the to the
police or whoever then of course uh
there will be a proper sanctions uh but
in the meantime i think what we should
do is uh let simon get on with uh let's
the cabinet secretary get on with his
job and i'm i'm sure he'll be uh making
his findings public as as soon as
possible
ben
are you are you restricting him to
looking at december the 18th i mean
that's that's
the guidance has been the
and the rules have been observed at all
times and uh he's looking at the uh the
issue of the 18th of december he may
wish to look at other things that's a
matter frankly for for him uh ben reilly
smith of the telegraph
thank you prime minister three quick
ones tory mps have suggested you've
called this announcement forward to
bounce headlines about the christmas
party is that true uh on christmas
parties and nativities what's your
message now to the country is that those
should be cancelled
and there's no time limit towards these
new restrictions or when they might be
considered when do you think the
earliest point that might be mid-january
february or spring
and a quick one for professor whitty
just picking up on your point about
reformulating the vaccines do you think
there's a real possibility a lot of
people might need a fourth vaccine
before next autumn to counter omicron
right thanks very much ben so look on
the first point we'll just imagine the
counterfactual um you know colleagues
say uh or people say that um
we're somehow making this announcement
to coincide with uh events in in
politics well actually uh imagine if uh
this step were to have been delayed
uh because of uh political uh uh uh
events of one kind or another what would
people say then uh
you've got to act uh to protect public
health
when
you've got the clear evidence and uh i
think it was i think i'm right in saying
that sage only met
uh yesterday uh to to discuss this uh
the the evidence about the
transmissibility of the viruses
we've been watching it for days but it's
become i'm afraid unmissable not just in
south africa but in this country as well
and
you know if you if you delay
uh as everybody knows with a doubling
time of two and a half to three days uh
you see uh more doublings and your
position becomes uh predictably uh and
inevitably
worse and more difficult to to recover
from on
on christmas uh
the best way to ensure we all have a
christmas as as close to normal as
possible
is to to to get on with uh with plan b
uh you know uh irritating though it may
be it is not a lockdown uh it is plan b
it is what we uh we set out uh a a while
back
and to get your get your boosters and
get your jabs that's the that's the best
way uh ford and as for when we'll review
the uh the the measures uh bear which i
think was your first your third point um
as i as i say no no later than than
early january and possibly before uh if
we start to get some of that uh really
really granular uh information but you
know
we need to we need to see the the data
and and work on it pretty hard
christmas parties and nativity yes sorry
no no
good good no they should not no so thank
you ben no uh in my view they should not
uh be
uh they should follow the guidance of
course but we're not saying we we don't
want uh kids to be uh taken out of
school before the end of term not that
there's a very long term to go now we
don't want nativity plays to be
cancelled uh we think that it's it's
okay uh currently on what we can see uh
to
to keep going with uh with christmas
parties but obviously everybody should
uh
exercise due
caution uh have uh ventilation wash your
hands uh
get a uh a test uh before you go uh a
sensible thing to do uh give yourself uh
we'll give everybody else at the uh the
party the confidence that uh you know
they're they're going to be meeting uh
someone who is who is not contagious uh
those are simple things that people can
do but that's what we're uh that's what
we're saying
on the question you asked me um i think
it's far too early to be sure on this a
lot of scientists are doing a lot of
work at the moment just to work out what
uh the current two doses
and different combinations of those and
the booster will do with uh the omicron
variant
um and that will help give us some
information i think until then it's
probably not very helpful to speculate
the exception to that
is that there's a very small group but a
very important group of people who've
got significant immunosuppression who uh
we've we're giving three doses to as
their primary course they will then get
a fourth dose which is essentially their
booster dose so in that group the answer
is yes but in the great majority of
people at this point i think the answer
is we'll have to wait and see what the
data show
just to build on that i mean
we've we've now got vaccine design that
allows you to alter them quite easily
and to make as chris said so called
multivalent or polyvalent vaccines
against different variants in one go
those are going to provide breadth of
coverage in the future
when they'll be needed we don't know
we've also got antiviral drugs coming
through now uh two have been uh reported
recently which have good effects so
they're they're increasing number of
options to look at this but
this is important going back to the
timing point sage met last week and met
again last night uh yesterday
on both occasions saying look this is
spreading rapidly you don't just watch
it spreading rapidly you need to do
something and that isn't just the
boosters the boost is incredibly
important but it's also about trying to
reduce the possibility of spread
which means reducing social contacts in
order to try and achieve that
thank you uh emilia casalique from
politico
thanks prime minister um you just
suggested that uh simon case could
extend this probe beyond just this
alleged party on their 18th the the
public secretary for the department for
education today said that
that party that happened at dfu that
they apologized for will be included in
that probe so obviously it's quite
flexible so would you encourage simon
case to look at all allegations of all
parties that might have happened in
downing street last year and also would
you commit to the inquiry being
published before the end of the year how
quickly would you like to see it done
yeah and then i've got a question for
the scientists maybe all three of you um
obviously just announced new
restrictions including a recommendation
from work to work from home
is the fact that we're here
doing this now not a mark of failure we
should have fixed the roof while the sun
was shining surely with the pandemic
prepare the vaccine booster roll out so
it could have been done at lightning
speed but instead it's been quite slow
to get this this new part of the rollout
sorted
actually created a proper world beating
test and trace system but it feels like
we're still not quite there yet as well
we went through devastation last year
but it feels like we still haven't
completely learned our lessons and when
are we going to learn because next time
we might be hit by a virus that's much
more dangerous than the pandemic so are
we going to be actually ready by then
right well look i mean just kind of go
emilia can i just go back on some of the
things you you've just said i i think
it's worth people bearing in mind that
there are a lot of countries uh
in our immediate neighborhood uh that
have got restrictions already far
tougher than ours and tougher than the
ones that we're asking uh people to
implement now much tougher and i think
people should always should also bear
and that's because we had the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe emilio just to
to remind you that and uh it is also the
case far from uh having a a sluggish uh
vaccine rollout uh
what we've now got is i think 21 million
people are having this a booster right
we've got 21 million people boosted and
again i think i'm right in saying uh
that whether
we we've boosted uh more people than any
uh comparable country and certainly
faster than any other european country
so i'm not going to hear any uh a
criticism of the nhs or the gps or
or the or the pharmacist or the
volunteers or everybody who's worked
blindingly hard to to get this done as
fast as they as they possibly can yes i
think what is abs well i think is fair
emilio is to say that we now need to go
much further and much faster
and you know having you know asking
people uh to to make further sacrifices
as as we are uh with uh with plan b
we've got to step up that booster
campaign and it's got to uh it's it's
got to grow wings and
we you know the pledge uh that everybody
uh over 18 will get the offer of
a booster by the end of january i want
to see us deliver that i i want to see
such a huge rate of booster uh
vaccination in this country that if as i
hope
the the boosters can hold uh
omicron then uh we can get back uh to
the road uh that we were on that's
that's what we're trying to achieve on
your on your other point about the
cabinet secretary as far as i'm
concerned uh he's got to get to the
bottom of uh of what he thinks is uh is
appropriate and and right but
you